[Music]
hey everybody welcome to qawalli Beach
Park this is Park which I'm gonna work
on in planet coaster and it's gonna be a
bit of a tropical Southeast Asian themed
Park but I'm not gonna work on this
alone I'm gonna work on this together
with karelis and ladies I know guys it's
Roos yourselves hey guys this Corrales
and welcome back everybody to the next
episode I'll plan ghoster so just sit
back relax and enjoy in today's episode
we're gonna build like an entrance
building right so yeah for sure
yeah okay okay and so anyhow I don't
know what to say hey everybody you're
gonna be amazing collaboration I guess
like um I'm with two of the best in the
in the middle field of this game so I
mean I myself is like the man but you
guys are amazing so I mean you're gonna
just carry me throughout usual series I
guess right I just wanna I just want to
see your interest and even better in
real life even live it's it's so good
yeah I totally agree on that my intro
yeah yeah by the way you are as well
yeah but you know what you know what I'm
gonna do you know what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna just an amazing blueprint options
I'm just gonna like it that's a nice
movie that is like you know you just
blueprint that and copy that you might
kill me okay what I've made a million
pieces so it's gonna be pretty amazing
but anyhow err I'm done with my
introduction I'm just I'm just here for
the right time to post it over to the
ladies on it
hi guys a lil a designer and I started
playing plank constitutes the 1st of
April in the alpha stage I really love
planet coaster and food was that hmm I
don't know was karelis oh there's
getting yeah sorry oh I'm sorry
so um I'm from the Netherlands as well
just like so Fred and well I'm just
looking so much forward to this
collaboration I think we are gonna make
a most brilliant park ever made oh yeah
oh yeah I totally agree it's gonna be a
kick amazeballs
oh yes I'm so much looking forward to it
so so can you tell me a bit more what we
gonna do a very good point so the way
that we're gonna do this right is I'm
gonna record the first episode right now
just through a time-lapse of making the
entrance building and a bunch of scenery
around that and then after that for the
next week I'm gonna give it over to the
ladies I know she's gonna work on her
part and after that she gives it over to
Corrales
he's gonna work on his part and then we
just close the loop and keep going like
that so each week we get another video
on one of our channels and we're gonna
put this all into one big playlist but
basically you're gonna have to subscribe
to these guys because they make awesome
planning coastal videos and if you want
to stay up the dates to what's happening
in this entire series you kind of want
to subscribe to every channel see what's
happening and see how everything's kind
of updating because you'll be able to
see what everybody else is adding to the
park too in the end make this one
complete awesome haul of tropical
goodness I think it's good to mention
that we're gonna upload our videos on
Saturdays as well very good point yeah
we'll be uploading it who will you keep
reminding me of everything I needed to
get Saturday's yeah we're gonna upload
this every Saturday so it's going to
come out once a week so the first
Saturday obviously it's going to be in
my channel because that's the video that
you're watching right now next Saturday
it's going to be on the lady's Channel
at the Saturday after that it's going to
be anchor Ellis channel at ceremony and
that's how it's going to work out and as
for the theme of the park itself it's a
little bit vague it's a bit like a
Southeast Asian theme and it's mostly
inspired by that area it's just going to
be a tropical kind of thatched roof tiki
huts a very nice and mellow sort of
theme like that so we'll be working a
lot with these different thatched roofs
and creating this sort of tropical vibe
with all of the palm trees and the
scenery and that's what we're going for
and hopefully it will turn out into a
charming and cozy inviting theme park
atmosphere um so much looking forward to
build mm-hmm seriously I can tell like
the engine G entrance you have made out
oh my gosh thank you so beautiful
exactly so yeah I seen yeah this is how
it's gonna work out I'll be seeing you
for
the rest of this video I'll just talk
alone I am sorry I'm gonna have to leave
these guys I'll just leave wow I am so
sorry I'm gonna I'm gonna talk about
what's gonna happen in the time lapse
alone and so is going to be the rest of
this series pretty much so I'll take you
through the rest of this video this was
just the quick introduction I am very
sorry to leave you guys behind oh I'll
see you soon don't worry but yeah I'll
be I'll be taking you guys you viewers
through the time lapse and the creation
of this station so let's say goodbye to
the ladies I know and karelis for now
thank you so much guys and I hope see
you next videos as well thanks for
having me for a few minutes
bye yes I'm just kidding just kidding
everybody enjoys the video and the
series and AM yeah good luck sill good
luck see you guys in a second alright
now I'm afraid you guys are going to be
stuck with me for the rest of this
episode of which is in line with the
format as it's going to be for the rest
of this series as well
because we just wanted to talk about
what's actually happening on the screen
as you seeing it and what we're doing
and I feel a little bit bad about this
because I haven't really said anything
yet about the entrance that I'm building
here even though it is pretty important
because it's kind of the prototype of
what the rest of the park is going to
look like it's quite simple actually
it's a bit generic and it's not very
pinpoint able to any certain given style
which is because we wanted to make this
quite a very broad style which a lot of
things can fit into so that all the
three of us can actually sort of do our
own thing and not have to assimilate too
much to what the other players are
making while still as a whole making
everything come together as one
hopefully coherent Park in the end and
because of that the style is sort of
broad so that a lot of different things
can fit into it
and we don't have to take realism or
like real life counterparts to strictly
when it comes to what we're building
here but it is very inspired by a bunch
of different real-life things which is
mostly just one thing that I was
learning over
it's got a lot of inspiration coming
from Southeast Asian architecture you
can probably tell by the touch roofs and
the shape that they have with a sort of
triangular Gables jutting out like that
that it's quite a bit of Polynesian
inspiration it also takes a little bit
for like Indonesian temples in the shape
that the building is laid out - the
little tower on top of it and in similar
ways there are just many of these
smaller parts and and set sections of
this kind of style that are taking
inspiration from like real life styles
but nothing is strictly taken from
anything in real life so it's it's just
the general tropical sort of vibe that's
supposed to have this very summery beach
huts sort of atmosphere to it and we're
just gonna play around with that from me
personally actually it takes a lot of
inspiration from some of the roller
coaster tycoon 3 sets like Polynesian
panic and jungle things which if anybody
remembers
I'll explain for those of you who
haven't played while ago second three
that religiously they were basically
sets with thatched roofs and a lot of
wood to create these sort of jungle a
southern sort of jungle huts or beach
huts that kind of stuff and that's what
this general style is going for as well
also a very quick note you might have
been able to tell that my voice isn't
actually that great which is something
that I can't really help I've been
having a cold ever since the beginning
of this week and I was well into my cold
actually when we record the when we
recorded the part with gorillas and the
ladies I know a little bit earlier but
at that point it was just sort of still
a sore throat and now my entire head
still been sort of closed up for a
couple of days which is why my voice
might not really be as decent as it
usually is and in case it is super
annoying to listen to I am sorry about
that I try to do some stuff about it so
I just came back from practice and my
head just sort of opened up for a little
it and I'm trying to take this window to
just record this video in the best way
that I can it's just a bit of a bad
timing B's we're on a deadline with this
thing and I would normally just push out
videos until I can record some decent
commentary again but there is no such
thing at the moment anyway just to come
back to the station a little bit so it's
got that inspiration from the Indonesian
temples in terms of how its laid out and
I just put that tower on top of it
because it seemed like a fitting thing
it's something that you very often see
on the in park entrances and in that
sense it's a bit of an American sort of
thing I almost feel like a little tower
on the fronts just on top of the gates
where you enter the park it's just that
that little theme park touch which makes
it look like an entrance building and
not just like any building that you can
pass through is that a little addition
that I wanted to add there and then
there are the wings of the building
which I'll add in a minute but first I
wanted to finish the plaza in front of
the station or the entrance building and
it's quite simple actually I just wanted
to put a bunch of planters on the sides
of the path here just to kind of prevent
it from being this very large open wide
plaza which just ends up becoming
feeling very empty I'm known as
atmospheric as I wanted this entrance to
be so I put a lot of planters down there
so I could put a lot of palm trees and
other trees in there and that's what we
just filled in the gaps with some
benches and lights which to be honest it
might sound very stupid but whenever I
have like some very large stretches of
path left over and you don't really know
what to do with it but you can fill it
in with a sort of area where guests can
sit about and just relax
it usually works quite well to just add
some benches some little bins and some
lanterns in there just to lighten up the
mood a little bit make it come to life a
bit but also fill in the empty lists and
I don't want to be too much like you
need to fill in every single spots of
your Park because you can definitely not
really appreciate how filled in and
charming some areas are if some other
areas aren't
or open and less detailed but especially
with areas like this where I really
wanted to make a nice atmospheric
entrance into the park which already
kind of sells you on the general
atmosphere that you're going to feel
inside the park itself I really wanted
to just make it as cozy as I could and
one of the things that I also wanted to
do to create that was my weird little
experiment right here that I just
figured out of the blue would be a
pretty cool idea if it would actually
work is a park entrance sign now I built
the posts a little bit earlier just
there with a couple of wooden items and
I eventually gave up because I didn't
really like any of the signs in the game
I really want to be the letters to go
along with the wooden arch that I have
over here so we'll be coming back to
that later I didn't mean to make this a
cliffhanger but when I was playing the
game I just figured nope we're gonna do
the the wings of the building first and
then we're gonna head back to that part
so that's why and over here I was
actually making a bamboo fence at first
out of different planks to make like
round bamboo posts which actually does
work quite well it does have a very
similar texture and shape to it the only
issue is that it takes a complete
buttload of blanks and it would have
definitely caused some lag issues at
later stages and I remember karela story
telling me that I needed to keep my
ridiculous amount of detail lower so
that we wouldn't run into framerate
issues later on during this series so I
eventually just ended up making that a
simple wooden plank post wooden plank
fence which works alright all the same
actually think it might be a little bit
better since the detail of having these
planks be round is just maybe too much
you don't really notice it that much but
it's still a bamboo kind of sort of
fence and I hope to maybe do a bit more
with the idea of creating bamboo out of
the wooden planks and seeing wherever
that's really useful
now just finishing up the wing buildings
which I wanted to do this in a
time-saving manner and not spend too
much time on this and also since the
central building of the station
or I keep calling it station I have no
idea where that coming when it's coming
from but I'm since the since the central
building of the entrance is already
symmetrical I also wanted to make the
wings more or less symmetrical and are
actually going to be exactly symmetrical
I did want to get some slight
differences in between the the windows
and the doors and the placements of the
details just to make things a little bit
more interesting but in terms of how
they're laid outs and the roofs that
they have they're going to be the same
so it's one big cool symmetrical
entrance building I suppose and that's
the way that this is going to work out
so just creating one of the winged
buildings on the side here which are
going to be quite small but sort of
function as this wall to shield off the
rest of the park from the vision as you
enter the entrance here so you're really
going to step into the park at once I
didn't actually put any sort of like
stalls or information kiosks in these
buildings I could have done that but I
was thinking that a couple of planters
on the paths that I have on the entrance
Plaza are actually going over the paths
and I was very afraid that adding shops
into these buildings which creates parts
for the guests to walk around in which
they just walk straight through the
scenery which is why I ended up not
placing any shops or anything in these
buildings I might mess around with this
a little bit more in the future just
place a shop in there and see if the
guests are actually going to walk
straight through my scenery which I
placed over the paths if not I suppose
that's just a great little addition to
the pike but if they are that's just
sort of a shame and we can just leave
these things be useless on the back I
mean these buildings aren't really that
important in the end they're just sort
of here to provide additional supports
to the side of the station and make it
look a little bit more like a cool large
station as you oh my god I just called
it the station again Wow
anyway yeah the entrance the entrance
it's just going to make the entrance a
bit larger and
well the entrance does fulfill is sort
of weeny function in the park it's going
to be some sort of large building since
it's at the end of this very large
Avenue and you want something that
attracts the guests and really draws
them toward the entrance and into the
park so I wanted to make something
that's quite big and the sort of wing
that fills up your entire vision as you
walk to what it so that's why we're
having some wings on the side here now I
didn't want to leave them completely on
detailed so I did put these couple of
planters as well as some other scenery
in here I'm actually quite a big fan of
how the rocks turn out I didn't really
talk about it much so far but one of my
favorite things to do in the game still
and it's only beginning easier and
better as the game has developed over
time is to make your accustomed a path
curbs and paths fences you just get one
simple roof piece just kind of sink it
below the ground so you actually have an
official building according to the game
and then put the different items that
you want to make your curb or fence out
of together and copy those around until
you really have what you're looking for
and it works with these kinds of rock
curbs since it sort of has that a
tropical touch to it
it also makes the entire look of the
part a little bit less monogamous but
also it works with fences just make one
part of a fence and copy that around to
make some custom fences you can do it
with a combination of both definitely
and I'm actually doing it a little bit
more over here so I'm thinking that
little roof piece underneath the ground
so you don't really see it anymore
and putting a bunch of different wooden
posts together to make a very simple
fence and it's definitely a super simple
fence I could have taken one of the
fences from the game itself like there
is a wooden fence there are some
different sort of rope fences as well
but I actually wanted to do this kind of
thing to have a much larger variety and
give the park its own unique kind of
fences because I'm actually a pretty big
believer in the fact that these small
path details like lamps and fences and
benches actually have a lot of power as
to how
certain scene looks and having the same
kind of lamps and benches and fences
everywhere just kind of kills the entire
mood or unique feeling that you might be
going for in a park which is just why
I'm personally a very big fan of making
things like these custom even if the
pre-given ones in the game are already
really good anyway speaking of good
things and this is one of the things
which I'm actually really happy with how
it so now it's in the end I wanted to
make the sign in front of the entrance
right here which is quite simple
actually it's made up of a bunch of
wooden brackets I realize that I'm
calling everything simple at this point
but it really in concept it is very
simple just putting a bunch of wooden
brackets together as letters and one of
the things which has been made super
easy recently is that you can actually
take different pieces within one
building so long as they're not great
spawning pieces like walls or roof
pieces and move them around at the same
time using the 3d gizmo tool which means
that you can make separate letters
inside your building nor even putting
them where you eventually want them to
be and then when you're done making the
letters just kind of fit them into place
which is what exactly what I did with
this sign just made some separate
letters and afterwards fit them into
place on the side where I wanted them to
be and this kind of thing would have
been a lot harder with the early systems
where you couldn't do this 3d gizmo
trick and it's one thing that has really
helped making buildings not just a lot
faster but also a lot easier it's given
a lot more options and it's definitely
something that I want to take advantage
of a bit more and experiment what you
can actually do it in the future now
finishing up the final touches of the
entrance area over here I'm not
recording absolutely everything there
are some parts that are left out
especially at the end of this but there
are still some things that I wanted to
show and one of them was actually
detailing the parts right here which is
just putting the lamps and the benches
and everything down and again just to
get that atmosphere that I was looking
for I had the in-game lanterns
a placeholder right here before but I
actually wanted to have some bamboo
light holders in the center of the path
because it's it's got a special place
it's the place where everybody's going
to walk and it's the kind of place where
I wanted to have special lights and in
this case a combination of some bamboo
posts as well as some smaller details
and some hanging lanterns which you can
actually make out of different pieces
that come with the game it's all super
customizable I actually decided to make
these kinds of lanterns and just post
those between the benches where I used
to have just the in-game lamps before
and pretty much of the in-game lamps to
the edges of this Plaza because I still
wanted to have some lights and the edges
but I didn't really want to go for the
special sort of decorative lights which
I have over here they're more of just a
functional light whereas the lights in
the middle of the plaza are much more
than just bringers of lights in a sense
they're really trying to add to the
atmosphere of the plaza as you walk into
the park now very finally some of the
terraforming and the foliage work around
the edges of the pot which was actually
relatively quickly done but it's one
thing which really dictates how the rest
of the entire plaza is going to look so
I wanted to get this just quite right
and with the combination of the
different grass textures you can
actually prevent sand textures from
going in certain places you so you can
kind of direct the sand as if it were
moved by the wind in certain streams so
that's what I was sort of trying to do
there with the different areas with sand
and grass and then after that fill in
the area with some tropical looking
trees a little bit of shrubbery here and
there especially around the trees though
not as much straight underneath them and
some palms and ferns just to outline
them and give them that little bit of a
tropical touch but I didn't want to do
it too much especially since the the
palm trees and the ferns can be quite
overbearing if you're using a lot of
them which is something that I might get
into later as well but especially in
this kind of climate you don't want to
end up make
a palm tree forest instead just kind of
use them in planters and use them as
highlights around other patches of
foliage that you have anyway that's just
about it for this episode thank you guys
so much for watching this and I hope to
see you guys in one week perhaps on the
lady's inés Channel and she's gonna pick
up the park file and go from here
or in two weeks on the corral assist
channel when he's going to work on it or
perhaps in three weeks when I get it
back from karelis and I can do some more
work in the park so hope you guys
enjoyed I'll see you later
[Music]